now to poland which has one of the
strictest abortion laws in europe
banning the procedure in all but a few
cases now the government wants to go
even further by creating a legal
register for all pregnancies dw's
alexander fernand reports now on an
issue that often pits individual women
against hospitals and the police
claudia kustob 26 years old entrepreneur
earlier this year she decided to end an
unwanted pregnancy using abortion pills
she ordered on the internet
i went to a hospital just to confirm
that i'm not pregnant anymore
but once there i was brutally examined
the doctor didn't provide any medical
information instead she scared me saying
the state prosecutor needed to know that
she would report me to the authorities
despite poland's near total ban on
abortion women who terminate pregnancies
cannot be prosecuted under polish law
that however didn't prevent the police
from interrogating her claudia kustov
tells me
they wanted to know how the pills were
delivered what the package looked like
i had to give them the names of all my
friends who knew i had an abortion
no idea what that was for
last year a court ruled that abortion in
poland is only permitted in cases of
rape or incest or when the mother's life
is threatened
thousands took to the streets in protest
antonina lewandowska was one of them the
reproductive rights activist says that
the results of the new law amount to
torture this ban on abortion
means that polish women are forced to
carry pregnancies
with fetuses that have no brain that
have no skull with their intestines
outside of their body with lethal heart
failures
it's just impossible to describe how it
feels like to be a woman in poland today
as of january the government also plans
to introduce a centralized register
where pregnancies and miscarriages are
reported pro-choice activists fear this
database could be used to cause legal
problems for women who use abortion
pills or find other ways to end a
pregnancy piercing
is a gynecologist in wut he says the
concerns about the register are
unjustified as the data is available
anyway but he also says he is fed up
with the issue being politicized in
poland
we as doctors would like to be left
alone by politicians we want them to
stop using us for their purposes both
sides are doing it
piotr shiroshevsky fears the restrictive
abortion rules in poland will have
lasting consequences
there are women who now are afraid to
get pregnant
they think what am i going to do when i
find out my fetus has an illness or gene
damage
that's why they decide not to get
pregnant at all
others skip prenatal examinations
because they fear the results
but the debate in poland continues with
pro-life activists demanding further
restrictions and criminal charges
against people selling abortion pills
the activists who sell the pills
earn money on that and this is what we
want to stop we want to stop this
business of
business of death you could say
claudia kustup cannot come to terms with
what's going on in poland she's hoping
for a political change soon otherwise
she says she's going to leave the
country
well for more let's cross over to our
correspondent mike elena
in warsaw magdalena i understand polish
lawmakers are working on further
measures related to pregnancies and
abortion tell us what's in the pipeline
well the government wants to establish a
central register including the
information about pregnancy which is as
they say just you know to provide the
best medical care um for instance in
cases of emergency but you know it
became a source of a suspicion of course
and uh since the abortion and abortion
law in poland become as such a disputed
area what i want to say is you know
maybe in other times and other countries
that would not be such a big topic
as it became now in poland when of
course there is a lot of inconvenience
what for the register is being planned
rights activists in poland have staged
multiple street protests against tougher
abortion laws have these protests had
any impact on lawmakers
well i don't think so indeed because
there has been so many decisions made in
uh last month in poland by the ruling
party law and justice and there have
been a lot of protests in several cases
and
they did not indeed change the decisions
of the government but just to be
precisely you know there has been even
an idea to tighten um the law which we
have now in poland and the ruling party
was as
the majority of the parliament against
it so um it also shows that they might
maybe not be any further step in the
abortion
law itself so where do you think things
will go from here in poland's abortion
debate given that the country already
does have very restrictive laws in place
yes it's hard to imagine that it could
be even more restricted it is now you
know uh abortion is just legal as it was
said in the report in two cases rape
incest or or um the threatened health of
the mother um so this is already a very
restrictive things and of course there
is a debate going on
among doctors and in hospitals there has
been also a hospital in the eastern part
and of poland
which
declared that
doctors are hesitating
of some steps because they are afraid
of what might happen to them so there is
a big debate going on in this country
and we never know how it ends because
the society is very strongly divided
also in that case in poland
magdalena thank you very much that was
dw's magdalene
in warsaw
you